what will they do once cobid comes back
the same people who are out on the
streets right now saying my body my
choice leave me alone my body individual
rights personal autonomy etc etc they
will be demanding that you be injected
with their experimental concoction of
lunacy that's what they'll be doing and
it will be cheered on by all the
mainstream media we put this video
together i think connor this might be
your finest work it's just so perfect
here's whoopi goldberg
versus whoopi goldberg
i don't want to force anybody i don't
want anybody coming in my house telling
me how to raise my daughter and what she
needs because they don't know well you
know it's my rights and but okay
but i don't
care
i will tell you this is my body
and nobody you you know you've got
people telling me i gotta wear a mask or
don't wear a mask or do this everybody
wants to tell me what to do but you
won't let me make my decision about my
body you are not
the person to make that decision my
doctor and my self and my child that's
who makes the decision we need to do we
need to do this and it's not gonna it's
not gonna allow us to be without masks
until we all do it because quite frankly
i'm not going outside until i know
everybody outside has had the shot when
you tell me
what i need to do with my doctor and my
family how dare you how dare you tell us
what to do well put a damn mask on
because you know i'm sick of talking
about your rights
let's talk about my rights my rights are
as
important to me as yours are to you i
don't want to get sick put a bloody mask
on man girl please stop talking
[Laughter]
girl please stop talking connor you're
getting guacamole today uh that's just a
perfect example of what these people do
right two years of you have to behave
how we want you to behave you have to
inject yourself with certain things you
have to put masks on your face and now
for the last two weeks leave me alone
the government has no right to do
anything i don't have to listen to
anybody else i am in charge of my own
health care blah blah blah blah blah
that's not evolving politically that's
devolving politically in your thoughts